most people are like petrified for a
ball to drop ask a boring question yeah
you do so much it yeah and I struggle a
lot with like I guess chunking up things
that I want to do CU like I'll have a
product I want to do I'll have something
I want to write I'll have this I want to
do Platform to focus on like how do you
Chunk Up couple things work for me one
I'm not scared to lose so I think a lot
of times a lot of people don't do a lot
of things cuz they can't take the L when
you're doing 31 things like seven are
going to fail quickly and I'm just okay
with that and I think that's one thing
to think about how old are you I'm 26
yeah I mean there's just some there's a
level of practice to it cuz I like
juggling 30 balls cuz I'm okay with
seven of them breaking most people are
like petrified for a ball to
drop